dude Bart did that to me too when I
talked about how this guy put hands on
me one time when I fell asleep at his
house and then yeah Bart was like did it
feel good
because I've never talked about this but
I was definitely sexually assaulted oh
really oh yeah for sure I used to hang
out with a buddy from work we were chill
one night we were all hitting up bars
and [__] and then after we went back to
his place to crash and I woke up and the
dude was next to me with his hands all
over my dick
and I was like
I remember I remember the whole room was
quiet that's when I was like oh these
are my people because everyone's
supposed to go oh I can't believe that
happened
I prefer that that's where I came up
people always take that [__] wait wait
seriously for you and I'm like oh you
don't need to do this for me I'm good